depuis le 15 mars le temps s'est figé
dans cette mosquée de courbevoie
confinement oblige
othman lahlou ne peut plus accueillir
ses fidèles exceptionnellement il a
accepté de nous ouvrir les portes de sa
mosquée nous maintenons toujours le
contact avec nos fidèles via les réseaux
sociaux internet
nous avons toujours maintenu un rappel
le vendredi vu la situation nous pouvons
être plus flexible plus à l'écouté et
plus dans la transmission à nos enfants
et à leurs proches
il veut rappeler aux musulmans le sens
premier du ramadan le ram annoncé le
mois par excellence de partage et de
solidarité
l'objectif du mois de ramadan ces deux
jeunes et toute une journée c'est pour
vivre et se mettre dans la peau de des
gens qui sont dans le besoin de ce site
au la solidarité une valeur essentielle
pour les bénévoles de l'association
culturelle des musulmans de courbevoie
depuis le début du confinement ils
distribuent quotidiennement des plateaux
repas au personnel soignant
pendant ce mois du ramadan ils offriront
des repas aux nécessiteux sans
distinction de religion ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'en fait on ne fera rien
me dit on va plutôt s'organiser pour la
fin de journée
on ne recevra pas les fidèles ou les
personnes à terre d'un moustique puisse
la mosquée fermée c'est important de le
préciser
fontaine complètement donc on ouvrira qu
une porte vers ce moment là les
personnes passeront devant la porte
il ya le conte drôle donc leur sac et
partiront avec ça on ne fait pas de
distinction entre les jeûneurs ceux qui
ne sont cette année et l'iftar la
rupture du jeûne au coucher du soleil
sera également soumise à l'épreuve du
confinement sa de repas collectif à la
mosquée ni de rassemblement entre
voisins ce moment habituellement
convivial sera réduit à l'échelle
familiale où on est assez rapprochées
d'arc spirituellement mais aussi
physiquement il ya les prières du soir
il ya le partage des repas de ce qu'on
appelle l' iftar c'est une fête par le
ramadan c'est aussi un moment 2h02 de
convivialité et de moi je dirais presque
deux rassemblements cette année ça va
être un peu c'est un peu différent avec
le confinement qui dure maintenant
depuis plus d'un mois
cette manière d'être resté chez soi à la
maison c'est aussi un retour vers soi
même de sorte d'introspection de sur
soi-même pour dire qu'est ce qu'elle est
vraiment l'essence de ma vie qu'est ce
que j'apporte et voilà pourquoi on a cet
élan de générosité qui est presque plus
important cette année que les années
passées pendant ce mois sacré qui débute
dans des circonstances qui n'édite les
musulmans veulent sauvegarder
l'essentiel se détacher du superficiel
et plus que jamais venir en aide aux
plus démunis